I know the whole house will want to join
me in expressing our sympathies to the
families of those who lost their
children in solihull and with your
permission Mr Speaker I'd like to make a
statement on illegal migration
I hope the whole house would agree that
there is a complex moral Dimension to
Illegal migration
the balancing of our duty to support
people in dire need
with the responsibility to have genuine
control over our borders understandably
provokes strong feelings
and so which is my view
that the basis for any solution
shouldn't just be what works but what is
right yeah
the simplest moral framing for this
issue one I believe members on all sides
of this house believe in
is fairness Mr Speaker
it is unfair that people come here
illegally
it is unfair on those with a genuine
case for Asylum when our capacity to
help is taken up by people coming
through and from countries that are
perfectly safe
[Applause]
it is unfair on those who migrate here
legally when others come here by
cheating the system
and above all and above all it is unfair
on the British people who play by the
rules when others come here illegally
and benefit from breaking those rules
[Applause]
so people are right to be angry Mr
Speaker because they see what I see
which is that this simply isn't fair
it is not cruel
or unkind to want to break the
Stranglehold of criminal gangs who trade
in human misery and who exploit our
system and laws
enough is enough
as currently constructed
the global Asylum framework has become
obsolete
today there are 100 million people
displaced globally hostile states are
using migration as a weapon on the very
borders of Europe and as the world
becomes more unstable and the effects of
climate change make more places
uninhabitable the numbers displaced will
only grow
we have a proud history of providing
Sanctuary to those most in need
Britain helped craft the 1951 Refugee
convention to protect those fleeing
persecution
the right honorable member for
maidenhead passed the world's first
modern slavery act in 2015.
and in the last year
we have opened our hearts and our homes
to people from Hong Kong Afghanistan and
Ukraine
[Applause]
thousands of families will be setting
extra places around the Christmas table
this year no one no one can doubt our
generosity of spirit
but today
far too many of the beneficiaries of
that generosity are not those directly
fleeing War zones or at risk of
persecution that people crossing the
channel in small boats
many originate from fundamentally safe
countries
all travel through safe countries their
Journeys are not ad hoc but coordinated
by ruthless organized criminals
and every single Journey risks the lives
of women children and we should be
honest mostly men at sea
Mr Speaker this is not what previous
generations intended when they drafted
our humanitarian laws
nor is it the purpose of the numerous
International treaties to which the UK
is a signatory
and unless we act now and decisively
this will only get worse
already in just seven weeks since I
became prime minister we have delivered
the largest ever small boat deal with
France with significantly more boots on
the ground patrolling their beaches for
the first time UK and French officers
are embedded in respective operations in
Dover and northern France we've
re-established the Calais group of
northern European nations to disrupt
traffickers all along the migration
route and last week this group set a
long-term ambition for a UK eu-wide
agreement on migration now of course
this is is not a Panacea and we need to
go much further
over the last month the Home Secretary
and I have studied every aspect of this
issue in detail and we can now set out
five new steps today first
our policing of the channel has been too
fragmented with different people doing
different things being pulled in
different directions
so we will establish a new permanent
unified small boats operational command
this will bring together our military
our civilian capabilities and the
National Crime agency it will coordinate
our intelligence interception processing
and enforcement and use all available
technology including drones for
reconnaissance and surveillance to pick
people up and identify and then
prosecute more gang lead boat Pilots
we're adding more than 700 new staff and
also doubling the funding given to the
NCA for tackling organized immigration
crime in Europe
second
these extra resources will free up
immigration officers to go back to
enforcement which will in turn allow us
to increase rates on illegal working by
50 percent and it's frankly absurd that
today illegal migrants can get bank
accounts which help them live and work
here
so we will restart data sharing to stop
this third
it's unfair
and appalling that we are spending five
and a half million pounds every day on
using hotels to house Asylum Seekers
we must
we must end this so we will shortly
bring forward a range of alternative
sites size disused holiday Parks former
student halls and surplus military sites
we have already identified locations
that could accommodate 10 000 people are
in active discussions to secure these
and More Mr Sunday flushed a camera then
oh it's it's quite serious to take
photographs in the chamber
no no there was a different camera can I
just say if the member knew they'd take
the photograph what
well I hope it's deleted and speak to
the side can you go out and just have a
chat with the surgeon because it didn't
move that way to me prime minister sorry
about that
is that we could have talked these sites
will accommodate 10 000 people and we're
in active discussions to secure them and
many more our aim is to add thousands of
places through this type of
accommodation in the coming months at
half the cost of hotels at the same time
as we consulted on over the summer
the cheapest and fairest way to solve
this press this problem is for all local
authorities to take their fair share of
Asylum seekers in the private rental
sector and we will work to achieve this
as quickly as possible fourth Mr Speaker
we need to process claims in days or
weeks not months or years
so we will double the number of Asylum
caseworkers and we are radically
re-engineering the end-to-end process
with shorter guidance fewer interviews
less paperwork and introducing
specialist case workers by nationality
we will also remove the gold plating in
our modern slavery System including by
reducing the cooling off period from 45
to 30 days the legal minimum set out in
the ecat treaty as a result of all of
these changes we will triple the
productivity of our caseworkers and we
expect to abolish the backlog of initial
Asylum Decisions by the end of next year
Fifth and most fifth Mr Speaker and most
significantly
third
all those arriving in small boats this
year almost 13 000 people are Albanian
and yet Albania is a safe prosperous
European country it is deemed safe for
returns by Germany France Italy Sweden
it is an EU accession country a NATO
Ally and a member of the same treaty
against trafficking as the United
Kingdom
the prime minister of Albania has
himself said there is no reason why we
cannot return Albanian Asylum Seekers
immediately
last year Germany France Belgium Sweden
all rejected almost 100 of Albanian
Asylum claims
yet our rejection rate
is just 45 percent
that must not continue
so today I can announce a new agreement
with Albania and a new approach
yeah yeah yeah first we will embed
border Force offices in torana airport
for the first time ever helping to
disrupt organized crime and stop people
coming here illegally second we will
issue new guidance for our caseworkers
to make it crystal clear that Albania is
a safe country
third one of the reasons we struggle to
remove people is because they unfairly
exploit our modern slavery system
so we will significantly raise the
threshold someone has to meet to be
considered a modern slave
for the first time we will actually
require a caseworker to have objective
evidence of modern slavery rather than
just a suspicion
fourth we have sought and received
formal assurances from Albania
confirming they will protect genuine
victims and people at risk of
re-trafficking allowing us to detain and
return people to Albania with confidence
and in line with the ecat treaty as a
result of these changes the vast
majority of claims from Albania can
simply be declared clearly unfounded and
those individuals can be swiftly
returned
and lastly we will change how we process
Albanian illegal migrants with a new
dedicated unit Expediting cases within
weeks staffed by 400 new specialists
over the coming months thousands of
albanians will be returned home and
we'll keep going with weekly flights
until all the albanians in our backlog
have been removed
and in addition to all these new steps
Mr Speaker let the house be in no doubt
that when legal proceedings conclude on
our migration and economic development
partnership we will restart the first
flight to Rwanda
so those here illegally who cannot be
returned to their home country can build
a new life there but Mr Speaker even
with the huge progress we will make with
the changes I've announced today
Bill remains a fundamental question how
do we solve this problem once and for
all
it is not just our Asylum system that
needs fundamental reform our laws need
reform too
we must be able to control our borders
to ensure that the only people who come
here come through safe and legal routes
however well intended our legal
Frameworks are being manipulated by
people who exploit our courts to
frustrate their removal for months or
years on end
Mr Speaker I said enough is enough and I
mean it and that means I am prepared to
do what must be done so early
earliest year
we will introduce new legislation to
make unambiguously clear that if you
enter the UK illegally you should not be
able to remain here
[Music]
[Applause]
instead instead you will be detained and
swiftly returned either to your home
country or to a safe country where your
Asylum claim will be considered and you
will no longer be able to frustrate
removal attempts with late or spurious
claims or Appeals
and once removed you should have no
right to re-entry settlement or
citizenship
and furthermore if our reforms in
Albania are challenged in the courts we
will also put them on a statutory
footing to ensure the UK's treatment of
Albanian arrivals is no different to
that of Germany or France the only way
to come to the UK for Asylum will be
through safe and legal roots and as
of those roots we will work with the
unhcr to identify those most in need so
the UK remains a safe haven for the most
vulnerable
and we will introduce an annual quota on
numbers set by parliament in
consultation with local authorities to
determine our capacity and amendable in
the face of humanitarian emergencies
Mr Speaker that is the fair way to
address this Global challenge
problem will not be quick
it will not be easy
but it is the right thing to do because
we can
we can with a system that was designed
for a different era we have to stop the
boats and this government will do what
must be done
[Music]
[Applause]
others will follow and I commend this
statement to the house